Shawn O'Hara NFL Network analyst former
Giants NFL lineman and judging from some
of the comments that he had yesterday
tweeted after Eli was benched so
incredibly disappointed and frustrated
with the Giants right now the defense
gives up 63 points in two games wide
receiving group is depleted but let's
change our quarterback and Shawn kind
enough to join us why did they make this
change Shawn hey Dan yeah great question
you know I I don't get it I had timing
is everything obviously I don't
understand the move after two weeks
granted this I'm not saying this is a
Superbowl caliber team but we started
out over two and 2007 and and turned
things around I just think the way that
they lost the first two games the fact
that the defense didn't stop anybody the
fact that you were going against two of
the best defenses in the NFL and the
Dallas Cowboys and the Buffalo Bills and
you did it kind of short-handed at the
wide receiver position
you know I don't think you got a great
glimpse of what your offense can really
be and do so it just doesn't feel like
they gave this year a chance I think if
we're talking about week six or week
seven and they've got one win or two
wins I think it's easy to wrap your head
around and you understand it but you
know this isn't about Eli being beloved
everybody loves Eli and you know his
legacy is already cemented but it's
about aren't you tired of losing aren't
you - what gives you the best chance to
win and contrary to public belief in
some areas Eli could still throw the
ball he made some great throws he missed
a couple things I guess Buffalo but he
still made some great throws the
touchdown throw TJ Jones in the back in
the end zone hit one receiver runner out
the other two guys had brain farts and
they didn't even go out on the pass play
and he found a way to make a touchdown
out of that he threw a great ball up the
sideline on third and nine and it gets
dropped right before the half and then
they miss a field goal right after that
so I feel this dysfunction
going on around the quarterback and I
see the same thing happening if you
switch out the quarterback so the
quarterback has been the biggest part
that anybody discusses for the New York
Giants and allies over the last three
years and the roster around the
quarterback has been awful that is
what's disappointing that's what's
frustrating we can sit here and talk all
we want about the quarterback play but
until you get a defense that can rush
the passer and affect the quarterback
rhythm until you get some people on the
back end
that can cover people until you get some
receivers that are gonna get open and
catch the football I don't care who
plays quarterback it's not gonna equal
wins and that's what I think Giants fans
are frustrated
I know Giants alumni people are
frustrated I know people in that
building are frustrated yeah but this is
what I think is happening Sean I think
that the Giants took inventory I don't
know why it took two weeks to take
inventory first of all I wouldn't have
brought Eli back because you drafted
this quarterback and today's day and age
when you draft a quarterback that high
he's playing pretty much right away but
I think Giants have taken inventory and
realizing we're not any good let's give
you a reason to continue to come out so
you can see the future here in Daniel
Jones
do I like him playing now I don't but I
wouldn't have brought Eli back if I knew
two weeks in that you were gonna have
Daniel Jones starting your thoughts I I
agree with at some point yeah you know
Daniel Jones is the future there's no
question about it as soon as he was
picked six overall it was just okay it's
Daniel Jones's team just when does that
start and you know III didn't think it
would start in week two you know I mean
so you know III still look at this year
and if I'm a player on that team you
know
don't don't tell me about next year
because if I'm on the last year my
contract or my signed a one-year deal or
if this is my 10th year in the league
you know I want to hear about next year
you think Kevin Zeidler wants to hear
about next year you think Nate's older
and some of these veteran guys that have
been around the league for a long time
next year is not given for anybody so I
need to find a way to try to win now and
I think you know one of the things
that's tough when
when you play a young quarterback is the
growing pains there are things that you
know you're gonna see as an offense with
a rookie quarterback that you're not
gonna see with the veteran quarterback
and I remember when Eli came in as a
rookie in 2004 we were five and four it
was week nine Kurt Warner was upset and
rightfully so because we had a winning
record we had a chance to still make the
playoffs and yet they brought an Eli and
guess what happened we lost six straight
games and that was it I mean we didn't
get a win until week 17 against Dallas
and that year was basically a wash and
you bring up a great point Sean because
I wanted to bring that up that you know
it's the circle of life for a
quarterback that Eli bumped Kurt Warner
who was decorated
you know won an MVP one is Super Bowl
and all of a sudden has a winning record
and then you get Eli in there after week
nine and he wasn't ready to go in there
but you know for whatever reason they
put him in there so Eli has to
understand he has to know what and I
know Kurt Warner was upset that they
benched Eli this way but you know Kurt
handled it like a professional and Eli
will too but you know do you keep him
does he go play someplace else do you
see him playing someplace else I don't
see it you know I know he wants to play
I spoke with him this summer and you
know briefly you just talked about you
know hey man is still burning and he
said yeah man I you know I love the game
and he loves not just the game cuz
everybody loves the games but it's do
you still love the preparation and and
everything that goes into it the
workouts to the offseason you know
training throwing doing all that he
still enjoys that I'll say this so Dan I
don't know if he's ready to
wholeheartedly put on another jersey
yeah you know I think when anybody knows
Eli knows that playing for the Giants
mean something to him being the
quarterback it's something special he
watched his dad had to go on move on to
another team as a young kid he saw
Peyton do it you know I think you know
there's some old school in Eli he's I
think it means something to him to have
only played for one team I don't think
it's you know certainly not financially
any motivation for
to go somewhere else you know maybe his
tune would change if the perfect
situation came about I mean he watched
Peyton go to Denver and win a Super Bowl
with a great team so maybe if something
like that you know he couldn't pass down
but I think given where his family
situation is you know I don't see him
wanting to go play somewhere else uproot
his family and do all that just to try
to chase down you know another year or
to see a hall-of-famer I think so
everybody has a different definition of
who belongs in the Hall of Fame there
are a lot of people right now that
belong in the Hall of Fame that aren't
in you know I think Carl banks should be
in the Hall of Fame hmm I think OJ
Anderson should be in the Hall of Fame
and they're not until Carrie Carson 13
times to get in yeah so you know that's
a frustrating process
but here's the way I define a
hall-of-famer was this player one of the
best at his position during an extended
period of time in the NFL during his
prime was he one of the best and Eli was
I think when you look at you know the
Super Bowls obviously people are going
to go right to that but I don't think
playing in the Super Bowl and winning a
suitable necessarily has to give you the
pass into the Hall of Fame at that
position it does though at quarterback
you know it's it's a bottom line sports
society and we want to know I'll do in
the big one it's rare when we go and
like Dan Marino was so special that he
lost his one Super Bowl appearance but
he was so special at what he did he was
ahead of his time you know that we you
know we we anoint him we grow like
Philip Rivers Philip Rivers gonna be a
Hall of Famer yeah really I think he's
got a shot man you're you're more
generous than I I am and here's my
saying I feel like the Hall of Fame
what's the big deal if we got five
floors you know I don't like how they
have made some guys that deserve to be
in there wait so long you know I know we
made the announcement that they're
they're gonna let ten people in this
year I think they should have no limit
on how many guys get in make it like
baseball and if you get enough votes to
get in you're in wait
sing to my show Shawn I've been saying
for years you have a basement 1st floor
2nd floor 3rd floor penthouse and you
want to have Montana in the penthouse
and you know whoever else and Brady and
that that's okay and if you happen to be
on the second floor then okay
you're still in the building that's all
you want to be in the building I think
the people in can would love a
skyscraper so yeah I'm with you on that
you know I think that the post you can
play to your point it does way more with
quarterbacks especially when you look at
the way that that Eli played so I just
kind of lumped the postseason into all
of it the post the playoffs and the
Super Bowl
Eli played his best football throughout
the entire postseason
now that run we had no seven he was
lights out it wasn't just a Super Bowl I
mean he played well against Dallas he
played well in Green Bay and that in in
the frozen game as we all know in in San
Francisco and the NFC Championship game
in 2011 he played lights out when it
mattered most even go back to the
playoff game three years ago in Green
Bay he played his butt off yeah
quarterbacks dropped the ball you got a
favorite story though you got a favorite
Eli story because I like all field or
anything because it doesn't sound like
people are got a lot of Eli stories with
his personality there's there's lots of
great stories about Eli Simone you can't
always tell you could tell over a couple
beers you know you can't do it where
it's going to be regurgitating and come
back to haunt a penny pound of beers
oh yeah he can make them disappear with
the best of them you know so here's
here's one you know Eli look he's always
taken care of guys he's always just kind
of been pure class he he'd always find a
way to have have some cold beverages for
his horses you know when after every
game no doubt but what you guys were the
horses yeah okay so he bought beers for
his line yeah okay but uh you know
there's there's some there's some good
stories I think one of the one of my
favorites is is probably in 2007 you
know there's two weeks before the Super
Bowl so we win the NFC chance of game
week
back from Green Bay we've got that first
week where you kind of put it put the
game plan in everybody's excited you're
trying to figure out logistics you know
travel tickets all this stuff so you
know that that week is a little bit of a
blur but you're kind of loose too
because there's no game you know and and
and you know people are having fun and
do all that so we had a good week but
then the next week are in now it's game
prep time so we we get ready to leave
our facility and we're gonna fly to
Arizona to get ready and I think it was
a Monday and we're flying out well we
could throw with practice we come in
nobody showers get cleaned up we had
meetings right after practice so guys
came in and some guys wind it right into
the meeting room and didn't shower yet
they were going to shower afterwards
well while we're in the meeting rooms
Eli has strategically had the equipment
guys buy dress shoes in all of his
offensive lineman's sizes and he had
them spray-painted bright purple and
bright pink and while we were in
meetings he had them go around and take
all of our dress shoes out of our
lockers and put these painted dress
shoes in so that we would have to wear
you wear a suit on the plane when you
travel that was Tom Coughlin's rule
attach significance to gameday so when
we came to our lockers and started
getting dressed and got your suit on you
pulled your shoes out of your shoe bag
and they were bright purple bright pink
and everybody's look around like what
the heck's going on here this was his
master plan to get us to have to walk
onto the team plane dressed like clowns
in these bright shoes
luckily for me I lived five minutes from
the facility I text my my wife who was
my fiancee at the time I said you gotta
bring me an extra pair of dress shoes
Elie stole our shoes I'm not dressing
like Bozo the Clown on the plane I'm
never gonna live it down so she bailed
me out brought me an extra pair of shoes
but uh Ricci soy Bert we're size 16 and
he looked like boazlin had to walk by
John Mara on the plane and John has
looked down and just cracked up laughing
and then as you got to your seat in a
shoe bag was your original dress shoes
so that so just you know as classy as he
always been is a great joke but hey you
know what here's your real shoes for
after
the prank is over with good to talk to
you Sean always great good luck the rest
of the season thanks for your time Matt
Shawn O'Hara NFL Network analyst former
Giants NFL lineman for more Dan Patrick
show tune in to audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]